gentlemen how are you doing
great
um i really want to start by saying
thank you so much for joining us for
joining me today uh to talk about your
fantastic movie um uh
i i have a lot of questions about the
film but i always liked throwing some
curve balls at the beginning to um you
know mix it up a little bit so uh
terence i'm going to start with you if
you could get the financing for any
project that you want to make what would
you make and why
wow
well it would be the the next film which
is um uh
called
the post office girl and is uh written
by stefan zweig um a great austrian
novelist who wrote the novella letter
from an unknown woman from which
officials made that fabulous film in
1949. um i i want to do that because i
think it's a wonderful book um which he
never actually finished he tinkered with
it um until he and his wife killed
themselves in rio de janeiro in the
mid-30s
but it is it's a wonderful novel because
it's a cinderella story with an unhappy
ending
it's knockout
it's so it's interesting you say that
because um uh i love movies that do the
unconventional ending or do things that
you're not expecting uh is that what
sort of is drawing you to it the fact
that it it has that unconventional
ending um no the the the unconventional
ending i said to everyone it's got to
stay we must not alter that no what drew
me to it is the fact that um here's this
young post office girl whose pair
they're living in austria just after the
first world war when the austrian
economy collapsed and um her aunt has
gone to america and married a dutchman
and they come back to austria and
they've been they invite her for a
fortnight
and she goes to this magical world where
everybody is no doesn't worry about
money and at the end of it she's still
about to go home and the the final third
of the film is her coming to terms with
that level of despair it's
wonderful but then i'm drawn to people
you know who are outsiders because i'm
an outsider myself um i
i don't participate enough i'm a
non-participant and the trouble of being
a non-participant is you usually get
ignored
[Laughter]
[Music]
well first of all i love the answer um
uh i'm so i'm curious i hope you get to
make that uh that project uh i'm curious
for both of you guys what do you think
would surprise for terence what do you
think would surprise people to learn
about being a director in the
entertainment industry and jack what do
you think might surprise people to learn
about being an actor
what would surprise people about being
an actor
um
i don't think a lot would surprise
people to be honest i really don't i'm
um it's a very hard question to ask when
to answer when you've been an actor your
whole life and so
i mean there is deep deep deep deep deep
deep set insecurity
that um just follows you around like
churchill's black dog
constantly
um
uh what's um
i'm not entirely sure what would what
would surprise people about being
are you
do you always feel like you're not going
to book another gig after you rap on
something
or have you gotten past that
no no no
yeah i'm almost at the stage where i'm
sort of like oh my god am i going to
book am i going to book another one
please no not yet
because i'm still recovering from the
last one you know it does um because it
does it does take it out of you it
really does but i i think
the the sort of um it's an incredibly
lonely profession you know it's it's
sort of is portrayed as if you're sort
of always surrounded by the fantastic
people all the time and you're you know
you're you're you're on yachts and
things like that but it is quite a
lonely profession because at one at one
point you're in a hotel room and then
you go to set and then that entire
machine just turns around and looks only
at you and everything that's been
worked on for maybe years and imagined
and envisaged
and paid for is then thrown completely
onto you um which is a pressure that um
a lot of people
have in very very different ways of
managing but it's um it can be it can be
it can be a very lonely place
because you are your art you are you're
you are the product you're the final
thing you are what you do
you are not a tape you are not a
carpenter where you can make a table and
then stand back and people look at the
table you're the table you know and and
so it's um
it's tough but it can be wonderful as
well
that's a that's a great answer thank you
for sharing
no problem and terence
what would people take from it poverty
because when you're not in the
mainstream you struggle for money all
the time um and i'm still struggling for
money you know um
literally
and that's no fun uh at 75 i didn't
think i'd be in a position where you
know um i'm in huge amounts of debt i
don't make films that are popular
and mainstream um
it took six years
for benediction to get to the screen
anyone with any sense
[Music]
wouldn't do it anyone with any sense
would just
go down the popular
route and make jane austen films
again and again and again
i i am happy that you make movies i'm
happy that you make the movies that you
make
and let's talk about benediction because
you did such a great job with this
material
for people that are not familiar with it
yet how have you been describing it
because i hate asking that generic
question but no one will have seen it
yet
well it's a it's about siegfried who was
one of the three great warpeds of the
first world war in fact we were the only
of all the combatants we were the only
ones who produced three great poets the
french
um had composers like ravel
um
but it's not just about
the first world war the first world war
is important because it actually
forged him into a great poet
but it's about other things too
making wrong decisions he this man falls
in love with the wrong people all the
time and the people he really does love
it never consummates it and this
constant
constant
journey towards some kind of
resolution some kind of peace of mind if
you like
doesn't come
but of course that's what makes it
interesting that's what makes it
interesting
uh jack you are extremely good in this
role and there's a lot for you to chew
on in terms of uh
there's just a lot to this role and i'm
curious how do you get ready for
something like this and um has your
process for getting ready for a role
adjusted now that you've worked a lot
more if you know what i mean
uh
it's um
it's my trust my process i don't have
one um i i i dif i just don't i
uh i seek to have one i i i long to have
one i long to have something that i know
i i can just like a jacket just stick it
on before i go in and it fits so
perfectly and i will be forever
and you know infinitely prepared for any
role i'm i
to me the the prep
is the thing that will be uh a lifelong
pursuit of how to prick in the best way
for a role because i haven't worked that
out and i've tried
different jackets on um in terms of prep
again and again and again because
it's once you're on set and once you're
surrounded by
phenomenal people when you have the
script and everything there
you know um
you're given a lot of help obviously but
when you're alone it's that's to me is
the hardest part of being an actor is
before you're on set it's the hardest
part because it's um
it's a discipline that very few people
have managed to sort of nail down a very
specific way to do it
um and it can be lost in a lot of crap
that people speak and um books that
people have written it's it's a very
very personal thing and it's to me
i would like to keep acting in this pure
pursuit of finding the best way to prep
because i i would um because it's the
prep that takes you away from your from
life from your personal from your
personal life
you know you it's it's those moments
where you're sat worrying oh god maybe
that isn't the right way to think of
this and
and it's um
but as soon as you walk on set it's sort
of almost irrelevant which you just
forget every time you start a new
project
um but uh in terms of in terms of
siegfried
the the the reason this job was was a
little bit easier was because of the
script
was because it's one of the best scripts
i've ever i've ever read it's it's and
maybe that's because i could i could
uh relate to a lot of what he felt
um but um it's it was a lot easier with
this because you had such a brilliant
blue blueprint and quite often you
really don't have a good blueprint
i think one of the things that the film
does so well one of the many things is
that it feels like it's accurately
portraying what it was like for
uh people that were gay um you know a
long time ago 100 years ago or
you know give or take 100 years ago
and one of the things is the fact that
like affection could only be a handshake
basically in public um and you there's
like a scene where anyway i thought that
was very good um can you both sort of
talk about um how difficult it was for
for people and those kinds of in those
kind of relationships back then and uh
uh just with the world you know what i
mean hopefully i said that right
but you must remember they come from the
upper class so they could get away with
it you know um because they knew the
right people i mean stephen tennant was
almost like a woman he dressed like a
woman and was extremely effeminate so if
you had the right
connections it was okay but if you were
in the lower mid class or working class
you know you went to prison um
they've cushioned by that privilege um
which is something that i personally
don't like um
but
it was very often
i don't know i don't know i was going to
say so
it was still difficult obviously one
can't take away that difficulty but they
were cushioned and protected by their
privilege they just were
i guess also when you're making when
you're performing and on stage and you
are making people money i think that
probably helps
well if the film makes monday no i meant
yeah i meant back then with the some of
the people in the film but yes i know
what you're saying
no it's it's a particular class of
people
yeah and it's it's the upper class
i don't know if you want to add anything
jack or i can move on
no i did that that's that was the thing
that stuck out to me was was
you know i think
a lot of people are probably going to
take that element away about his story
but
that was fairly evident fairly quickly
that as taran says you you were dealing
with people
of a certain class with a lot of money
and weight and power and connections
that probably the uh
the the outcomes of living as either
privately or openly gay were nowhere
near as severe as they could have been
to to those in in the lower classes
which is it which
you know which is a thing that
back then was one of the great blights
of the united kingdom was the class
system which is still eating away at us
constantly so um no it's it's and it
played a part of of sassoon's story in
this film but it's it's definitely not
everything that the story is about
um
[Music]
it's
it's secondary to his regret and as
terence would say is his seeking for
redemption really
um terence you use old footage in the
movie and you know you you splice it in
to help tell the story where did that
idea come from
well very simple um
even if you had billions and billions
and billions of dollars you cannot
recreate what it was like in the
trenches you just can't um and yeah i
saw that footage and it was
it's
deeply moving horrific but and some of
it's extremely beautiful and the other
cliche is that in a lot of films about
the night then the first world war
there's this wonderful long edwardian
summer well where everything is so
beautiful and exquisite yeah if you're
of the right privileged background if
you work in a factory or down a mine it
wasn't so i did what i wanted to avoid
that cliche so i thought i will make the
interiors some tours
so that when you see that footage that's
what they're going to and that's where
they come back from
it was that was absolutely it
and the difficulty was um of
choosing the footage because there's so
much of it which is
appalling
it's appalling
but it is mesmeric
i'm i'm basically out of time with you
guys but just real fast i want to ask
one last thing one of the things that's
interesting about siegfried is that he
is and jack you touched on it he's
always so looking for this sort of
redemption can you sort of talk about
that aspect of
of the film and of him
well he he um
that's where i identified with him very
well
was and very easily i read his memoirs
um uh before i read his poetry and his
memoirs are to me almost almost more
revealing and my favorite part of his
writing that's just personally
um
his uh his hypocrisy and his recognition
of his own hypocrisy is the for me the
most endearing thing about him and um
it's something that in in a time in an
age
of where everybody has to right now
you know put their flag in the ground
and stand for and cry and burn and die
for
one thing that they believe in and must
never ever think something else must
never ever change their mind
that was the most refreshing thing for
me was to to to look at a man who quite
openly even though in his memoirs but i
imagine he was probably like that in his
private in in public with his friends is
not afraid to say that i i think this
but i'll probably think that in the
morning and i think those are where the
really interesting discussions are and
where great art comes from obviously so
um
that that for me was one of one of the
main lines in him
that i i just fell absolutely fell in
love with because we don't see it that
often anymore people people who
contradict themselves all the time
yeah brutal honesty is rare
yeah yeah yeah and the the ability to
say to wake up in the morning go you
know what actually i think what i've
believed in for 10 15 years is
completely and deeply flawed and that is
the great one of the great engines of
change
is is is hypocrisy sometimes
um i have to stop there i'm just going
to say congratulations on the movie uh i
really hope it's a huge hit for you guys
and parents i really hope you are making
another movie uh sooner rather than
later
thank you thank you
thank you good luck with the rest of
your interviews and um have a great day
thank you steve
thank you